[Applause]
[Music]
poland is a country that breaks all
stereotypes
on the one hand it is the most catholic
country in the european union
87 percent of the population of this
country is catholic however
poland's best known music group is
behemoth
an openly satanic black metal group
hell yeah but the stereotypes don't stop
there if there is one thing poland is
becoming famous for
it is its government one of the most
conservative in europe
in recent years poland has been in media
for news
like this
[Music]
poland judiciary reforms eu takes
disciplinary measures
bbc and the most recent
poland's top court rules that law
allowing abortion of fetuses with
congenital defects
is unconstitutional abc news however
despite all this
this conservative government has a lot
of popular support in fact in the last
presidential elections which were held
in the summer of 2020 the president
andre duda
won again
now the president is one thing and the
government is quite another poland has a
right-wing coalition government the most
important party
is the law and justice party which we'll
call the piss party because of its
acronym in polish
not really it's pis and this coalition
was on the verge of collapsing to dust
only a month ago and you're probably
thinking why does it have something to
do with the massive protests against the
abortion law is it because of
differences of opinion in the management
of the coronavirus
well typical for poland it's none of
those things
listen up because today's video will
break all the patterns and stereotypes
you had in your head because the
controversy in poland has come about
because of this law
[Music]
poland's ruling party says coalition
could collapse
over animal rights bill reuters that's
right it's an animal protection law
which prohibits using animals and shows
having them tied up for more than 12
hours a day
and a lot more we are talking about an
animal protection law that is much more
protective than those of many other
european countries and who proposed this
law
well none other than jaroslaw kaczynski
and who is kaczynski well only the most
important man in polish politics perhaps
if i tell you that you will think that
he must be the current president or the
prime minister
but he's neither of those things i tell
you that this video will shatter
all of your mental preconceptions
because until a few weeks ago mr
kaczynski was just
a former prime minister of poland
however kuczynski is to poland what
alvaro uribe is to colombia a very
influential politician
even when he does not govern and like
uribe kaczynski sits far
to the right of the political spectrum
well it was kozinski who used all of his
political clout
to get this lot out and you're probably
thinking why are animal rights
so important in poland why is it this
law that could bring down the government
coalition today we are going to answer
all of these questions
before we do we need to take a look at
lil history
x-ray of the polish right if we talk
about politics
poland is a very interesting case
[Music]
you see in most countries we could say
that there is on the one hand
a social democratic left and on the
other hand a political right that can be
more or less conservative or more or
less liberal however
in poland there is a centre or moderate
rate called the civic platform created
by donald tusk
this party is part of the european
people's party
[Music]
on the other side we have a much more
conservative right wing with populist
overtones
in this case we are talking about the
law and justice party or
pis not piss which has been governing
poland since 2015.
in other words the political debate in
this country is between the right and
the far right
and within this right of the right-wing
party which happens to be the one in
government there is a person who is the
jack of all trades of polish politics
we are talking about yaroslav kaczynski
kaczynski there is no ruler in our
country poland is a democracy our prime
minister leads the government
the president is fulfilling his tasks
but there is a little bit left for the
party leader indeed for 20 years
kaczynski has been the tireless leader
of the law and justice party and when he
says that he has
some leeway to govern from this position
which initially has
nothing to do with the executive it is
because the current prime minister
is an acolyte of kaczynski and president
andre duda was also promoted by the law
and justice party
so it seems that in this festival of
democracy everyone comes from the same
family
so much so that if you have not been
paying attention to polish politics in
recent years
prepare yourself because you will be
left speechless let me explain
imagine that in a semi-presidential
democracy the prime minister
and the president not only come from the
same party but also
have the same face that's right they
have the same face
they are the same and all that seems to
be the least of it they also have the
same surname let's see how you solve
this one exactly between 2006 and 2007
poland was ruled by twin brothers
literally let's kazinsky was the
president
and jaroslaw kozinski was the prime
minister i suppose they would kind of
have to agree amongst themselves never
to wear the same tie because otherwise
they'd basically be indistinguishable
but the story doesn't end here because
the kaczynski brothers were already
famous in poland before they entered
politics when they were 11 years old
they acted in the same film
[Laughter]
with stories like this it's
understandable that the kozinski's had
the affection
of all polls
[Music]
in 2001 they founded the law and justice
party together or
by its polish acronym the piss the pis
i'm going to stop now a conservative
party which borrows directly
from catholic values well in just five
years the pis
made its way to the government and
that's how the kaczynski twins took
almost all the power in their country
one as president and the other as prime
minister but this
beautiful family story had a terrible
ending in fact we are talking about one
of the saddest tragedies
in international politics
smolensk the tragedy that defined polish
politics
dw on the 10th of april 2010 lech
kuczynski was on a plane with many other
politicians the president of the central
bank the minister of foreign affairs the
minister of culture
and many many others when they were
flying over the russian city of smolinsk
the plane
crashed all of the passengers died
since then jar of slavs kozinski is the
sole undisputed leader of the polish
right wing he has never held public
office again
but at the same time he is the one who
makes the most important decisions
within his party this means that he
manages poland's domestic and foreign
policy and if
not how do you explain to me that a
gentleman who has no possession in
government
can make decisions like this one
poland's kaczynski says no to the euro
as part of election campaign
reuters furthermore although it is true
that he did not hold any publicly
elected office he did have enough
freedom to promote or remove
candidates from the head of government
he had so much power that some media
spoke of
disposable prime ministers if someone
stopped impressing kozinski he or she
lost their position this was the case
with mario incovets in 2006
or the politician could choose to resign
as brita siddillo did in 2017.
right now the polish prime minister is
matthias morowaki
who again is very close to kaczynski and
once again
i'd like to apologize to all of poland
for the pronunciation of those names so
who supports this man well more or less
half of all polls do if we use the
results of the parliamentary elections
of 2019 and the presidential elections
of 2020 as a reference the law and
justice voter base was traditionally
among conservatives and linked to rural
areas the church
remember we are talking about a country
where religion is a very important issue
almost 90 percent of polls declare
themselves to be
catholic
in addition one of the 10 most listened
to radio stations is radio mirage
directed by the priest tadius radzok the
radio station is also closely linked to
the law and justice party so much so
that even the vatican has expressed its
opinion on the political use that this
priest made of radio mirage in the
catholic religion
so you can imagine that kozinski's ideas
are more or less
the opposite of liberal we are talking
about a very conservative right wing
very catholic ideology which is against
abortion and also
does not look kindly on the arrival of
refugees or the rights of the lgbtq plus
population
in fact another very recent scandal in
poland was when a hundred polish
villages proclaimed themselves
lgbt-free zones they are declarations
that have
nothing to do with the law but with the
rhetoric
of the government
kaczynski calls lgbt rights a threat
to poland france 24. as expected the
european union has not liked all this
anti-gay bigotry and has already
announced that it is going to withdraw
funding for the country
this could be a real setback for poland
we are talking about one of the
countries that receives the most
european funds
you might think that these are the
reasons why the government correlation
is faltering
right not at all in reality the
discussions in the polish government are
about something
else entirely listen up
[Music]
strange bedfellows when we talk about
poland we usually think of the law and
justice it is kozinski's party it is in
government and has a lot of presence in
the media
all over the world what does not appear
so much in the media is that
pis does not govern alone it does so in
coalition with two other parties
it is called the agreement and the other
united poland
keep these names fresh in your mind
because they'll be very important
throughout this video
as you can imagine the two newer parties
are quite close
to the pis however numerically there is
no comparison if law and justice has 198
representatives in the shem which is
what they call the polish congress
these two new parties only total 37.
well
this conservative harmony was about to
explode in september 2020 and the origin
of the battle was none other than the
succession of jaroslaw kaczynski
that explains why we find so much news
like this in the polish press
ziobro is acting like a self-appointed
prime minister within the polish
government the tale
is wagging the dog viborcha so who is
zilbro well none other than the leader
of the united poland party which
as you know governs in coalition with
the pis
he is also the minister of justice so
the judicial reforms that have shaken
the european union are largely to his
credit you see
if any of you think that kozinski is too
conservative zeobro
is not far behind his party is against
abortion
gay marriage and the istanbul convention
against violence against women because
he says it is
a quote feminist creation to justify gay
ideology
end quote you know the famous gay
ideology that they too
are people and if zeobro's party
represents the most conservative wing of
the government
at the other end of the spectrum we have
the jaroslav godwin's agreement party it
is called
jaroslaw godwin's agreement party so it
is pretty clear who is in charge well
both united poland and agreement are
parties that are too small to be able to
really promote their interests but big
enough to counteract the power of the
pis
and as you can imagine kaczynski does
not like this
one little bit to all this add that
juster minister ziboro hates current
prime minister
moroecki so much so that murawaeki
himself has even asked kozinski to
remove zeboro from office and you're
probably thinking
but he's the prime minister can't he put
in the ministers he wants well the truth
is
he can't in fact the leader of the
polish right is kozinski so is he who is
the last word
in fact in a way we could say that these
internal fights are a battle for
kozinski's succession
[Music]
all of this brings us to september 2020.
let's put ourselves in kozinski's shoes
for just one moment
you are a 71 year old man you are the
most influential politician in poland
but your party is winning fewer and
fewer votes in the election
and your government coalition is engaged
in internal struggles add to that the
coronavirus pandemic at the time of
making this video the numbers in poland
were skyrocketing but back in september
the virus was under control now with
better or worse fortune the corona virus
can ruin
any government just ask former president
donald trump
so kozinski is in a complicated
situation on the one hand he would like
to expand his share of power
and calm the internal quarrels but on
the other hand let's be honest
no one would want to be at the helm of
poland or indeed any european country in
i think everyone would agree on this
merkel macron sanchez and of course
kozinski himself because we have several
years left in which power will become a
proverbial
hot potato all governments are passing
very unpopular restrictions meanwhile
there are companies going bankrupt
unemployment rising and lots of cuts to
jobs
and subsidies in other words the idea of
spending these years in comfortable
opposition really doesn't sound so bad
so
what has kozinski done well he's done
what you might call a political hail
mary and what does this mean exactly
well we're going to take a look at that
right now
the polish hail mary in american soccer
as i like to call it the hail mary is a
risky desperate and very very difficult
move
to make right it happens when the game
already seems over your team
is losing but suddenly you find yourself
with the ball you don't have any of your
team around you the other side is about
to take the ball
away from you that's when you do the
hail mary pass
that is you basically throw the ball as
far as you can and with a little look
you score
a touchdown or a goal or some sports
isn't my strong suit
well something like this is what our
friend kaczynski has done damn it i've
got nothing to lose so i'm gonna take my
chances if i lose
i'm off the hook for three years if i
win i'll clean up my coalition
[Music]
and this is where animal rights law
comes in and i know what many of you are
thinking i'm sure that being so
conservative kaczynski will be against
animal rights right normally this kind
of position is associated with the more
environmentalist left stereotypes though
are almost always wrong and this is one
of those cases because
my friends kaczynski may be as
right-wing as they come but he adores
animals
fun authoritarian fact so did hitler in
pre-world war
ii germany the nazis passed one of the
most progressive animal protection laws
in the world you see
even nazis care about doggos anyway back
to kaczynski and his love for animals i
haven't told you the story but this man
is single in fact
until 2013 he lived with his mother and
now the closest thing he has to a family
are his three cats
by now there is no paul who does not
know the great affection this man has
for animals and the truth is that he
doesn't really hide it either
[Music]
yes this gentleman is jaroslaw kozinski
in a session of congress and yes he is
flicking through a book
about what else cats
so as you can see he is very interested
in animals in fact
in 2018 he already tried to pass a law
against animal abuse
at that time he did not want to exhaust
all his political influence
getting it approved so parliament voted
against it but this time he came back
with his bill and take note because we
are talking about one of the most
protective laws for animals in all of
europe a law that would delight
any peta activist
kaczynski's law proposes the following
to prohibit the raising of animals for
fur that's for all animals
except rabbits because i guess rabbits
wronged him as a child out of that
or rabbits are part of that feminist
conspiracy and he just got
mixed up with the type of rabbit the
other one he wants to ban is the use of
animals for entertainment if someone
wants to organize bullfights in poland
why wouldn't you they'd have to look in
another country in addition kaczynski
wants to limit some rituals that involve
the suffering of an animal and to create
a special counsel to protect the rights
of animals in other words right-wing
tweeters
are really going to sweat when they want
to comment on this man but
stereotypes aside the question is why
are we saying that this law
is so risky in principle most people
like animals this could be a law that
the whole parliamentary spectrum likes
right so why is this law
so controversial in poland well right
now
let's check it out
[Music]
no country for vegans in the world today
there are three countries that are
leaders in the export of mink skins
china denmark and poland that's right if
you want to buy a fur coat
it is very likely that it will have a
label stamp made in poland
the fur industry generates thousands of
jobs in this country and those
are mainly rural jobs as i mentioned at
the beginning of this video one of the
sectors that most support the law and
justice party is precisely this
the rural sector so in this polish
version of animal farm those who
rebelled
are not the animals but the farmers who
had voted for the pis party in the past
and now feel betrayed but we are not
only talking about them but also another
sector of voters crucial to law
injustice do you remember
radio mirage and his controversial
director tadio sranzerk listen to this
they feel pity now over these little
furs father rydzick said recently
adding that the government should not be
focused on things like further limiting
abortion rights
let's not animalize man and humanize
animals
new york times yikes but anyway this law
hasn't just upset the catholic religion
it is a full frontal attack against
islam and judaism as well why
you may ask because muslims eat halal
food and the jews eat kosher food and
what is the problem with kosher and
halal food and animal rights well there
are a lot of them
[Music]
in its most orthodox aversion to prepare
kosher or halal meat you have to bleed
the animal while it is alive
and conscious that is you cannot sedate
or
stun it those who defend this type of
ritual assure that the bleeding doesn't
last
long in other words the animal dies
within a few minutes but there can
always be an error
one bad cut and the animal can suffer
for much longer which goes to explain
news headlines like this
[Music]
belgium region bans halal and kosher
slaughter of animals
euro news denmark bans kosher and halal
animal slaughter time
so at this point you're probably
thinking how does this affect poland
you've already told me that 80 percent
of its population is catholic and in the
other 13
will find all kinds of religion
interestingly poland has one of the
smallest muslim populations in
all of europe to give you an idea there
are more jehovah's witnesses in poland
than there are muslims
and jews combined however poland is one
of the leading exporters of kosher and
halal meat in europe we do not have
exact figures but we are talking about
an industry that moves
millions of dollars every year to give
you an idea poland is such an important
producer that even
israel has a problem with this law check
this out
[Music]
jewish leaders concerned over poland's
proposed banning of kosher exports
j post by now i think you can imagine
why this animal law is so controversial
basically it strikes a blow at its own
voter base at least those who work in
the country as you can imagine all of
kozenski's political allies have opposed
this law so how did kozinski respond
remember that we are talking about a 71
year old man a man who represents the
essence of polish conservatism well in
order to break stereotypes he has made
the most millennial decision
possible a tick tock profile was created
to broadcast a video response
defending his law
you know it's serious but when it's on
tech talk and what it says
basically is that every good person
should support this law and then
nominate guess who
his favorite prime minister matthias
morowaki and there you have it the truth
is that kozinski's move is more than
surprising because it is obvious that
many farmers who supported
the pis party in the last elections will
now look for another party but at the
same time this law
has received a lot of support among some
sectors that had never been interested
in law injustice before we're talking
here about
young people animal rights defenders and
short traditionally
left-wing voters and there's more the
bill has allowed kozinski to purge his
coalition which as you may remember
was fracturing
both united poland and ironically
agreement refused to support the animal
protection bill some of their
representatives voted against it and
others abstained from voting
and who's one of the main detractors of
the bill you guessed it the minister of
justice tobigano
zeobro and who voted in favour exactly
mr morowaki
but the story does not end there when
the bell passed through this gem that is
the polish parliament 15 representatives
from
pis itself also voted against it what
happened next
really fits the stereotypes well come on
this part probably won't surprise you
in case your polish is a bit rusty and
why wouldn't it be polish is a language
that looks evolves the same way scots
look at vegetables i will translate
all 15 including the minister of
agriculture were suspended from the
party and what happened to the coalition
at first it seemed that a collapse
was inevitable
[Music]
poland's law and justice ponders ruling
alone after united right coalition
collapses
euro news but this this is what the hail
mary is all about with a little risk
sometimes the impossible becomes reality
if the united right-wing coalition falls
apart
it is likely that poland will have to
hold new elections and in the year 2020
with a coveted pandemic no one wants to
risk losing their share of power in new
elections
so for the moment the coalition is
holding and
what happened to kaczynski he's back in
power that is back to official power
from now on he's the deputy prime
minister the truth is that at this point
the fate of the animal protection law
is not at all clear the senate approved
it with several amendments but
it seems that the protest cooled the pis
down a bit so
for the moment the bill is on hold in
the polish congress
in the meantime the government prefers
to focus its attention on other issues
such as restricting the right to
abortion remember that is exactly what
the priest thaddeus radzik was
asking for because you know animal
rights rather than
women's rights so in the end what has
kaczynski achieved the truth is that at
least in the short term the hail mary
has worked wonders for him he has been
able to weed out the opposition within
his parliamentary club and also within
his party and now both the pis
and kozinski himself are in a much more
powerful position so now the question is
over to you
do you think the bill on animal
protection will ever be passed more
importantly what do you think about this
law would you also ban animal shows and
halal and kosher food and most
importantly just how badly did i butcher
those poor polish names i'm pretty sure
for one the kaczynski
is the unabomber so i apologize poland
anyway
we really hope you enjoyed this video
please hit like if you did and don't
forget to subscribe for brand new videos
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider media podcast and they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not my dusted tones
also this channel is possible because of
patreon and our kind patrons on that
platform please consider joining them
and supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage and
as always i'll see you next time i'm
really sorry poland and if you want to
learn more about politics and hear even
more of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider
media.com podcast see you there